foreign
am very thankful that John and Jonathan
have decided to have a conversation with
one another
and I've been very much looking forward
to this since I heard they would be able
to make the time
so I hope that you will all enjoy Dia
logos between the two of them
[Applause]
so I wanted to start by uh
uh responding maybe even resonating is
the better verb to uh
masterful presentation of iconography
and um
so I want to if you'll indulge me I want
to say talk for a few minutes because I
can't make the point in a couple of
sentences
so
I've studied that's probably
insufficient I have been obsessed with
the problem of relevance realization at
the core of my career
um
and
it's now coming to the fore more and
more explicitly in cognitive science
um and for me that has been
[Music]
um
uh I don't know what to call it's it's
been it's it's encouraged me
so one of the problems
your cognition faces is the problem that
it can't be either algorithmic or
arbitrary it can't follow ultimately
rules that are working in terms of just
truth and falsity and certainty it can't
work just in terms of arbitrary choice
because for many real world problems
the amount of information you can pay
attention to is combinatorily explosive
the number of options in your search
space as many of you know a standard
chess game
there's on average the number of
Pathways potential Solutions you have to
search through is 30 to the Power 60
which is greater than the number of
atomic particles in the universe so
obviously you can't do an exhaustive
search so you can't do an exhaustive
search you can't be algorithmic but you
can't just arbitrarily pick from that
search space
um of all the information in your
long-term memory you can't search
through it all you can't search through
all the possible combinations that's
common sort of explosive
right and there's more and more
instances of these
um and so just gesturing to an argument
you've heard me make
endlessly
um
what's happening of course now and again
and get stuff getting published as this
is now coming into
the center of the of so we've gone
through the first debate we're now it's
called the second debate about
rationality Herbert Simon is playing a
pivotal lawn bowl but it's coming in and
it's causing us to really radically
reconceive the notion of rationality we
have to give up sort of the Cartesian
model
so
that's sort of on the outside that's
scientific but I want to now start to
resonate with
what Jonathan was talking about
kind of wondered what would happen if
I'd been brought up with a near Chris in
Christianity that was like what Jonathan
presented
I wonder where I would have ended up
um
so
let me give you a lot of instances of
these and I want to show you how your
biology solves this problem
because it it appears on many many
levels and I just want to give you a
bunch of examples fairly rapidly to show
you how comprehensive this strategy is
I'm doing all of this because I don't
think of evolution as an intentional
process but I'm also not trying to
insult any theists here trying to keep
this as neutral as possible
okay so give me some charity on that and
I will return the charity as many as
fulfilled as I can
so
you have you have to have a certain
amount of arousal and put aside Freud I
don't mean sexual arousal because there
should be long periods of time where
you're not sexually aroused uh but right
hopefully that's happening right now
um
I mean metabolic arousal
yeah and so the problem facing you is
what level should you have your arousal
at and the problem is you're on a
Continuum and you need to make it
sensitive to the context like I can't be
really highly aroused that's not good
I can't be
and I can't take sort of an overall
Canadian strategy I'll just be middle
all the time oh look a tiger right so
um so so what what's the solution well
one thing you might try is you might try
creating a system that is calculating
all the variables and then taking it
into like taking an input doing all the
calculation doing output and then trying
to manipulate a system
um
but instead what you have is you have
your autonomous
autonomic meaning from autonomous
self-law self-governing nervous system
it's divided into two subsystems there's
a sympathetic and the parasympathetic
and I'm going to and please understand
that I'm going to be using these words
from now some words very very carefully
here
the sympathetic system is biased
to interpreting as much as it can of the
world as threat or opportunity and
trying to raise your level of arousal
the parasympathetic system is biased to
trying to interpret as much of the world
as a safe context in which you can
recover and recuperate and Digest
and then what you do what you do is you
put the two together like this and
what's called opponent processing and
they're constantly pushing and pulling
on each other so you take two systems
that are heuristically biased they don't
search the whole Space they're very
biased
right and then you put them in an
opponent processing together and they
are constantly pulling notice what I'm
doing with my left and right hands
yes
yes right right left and right here I'm
pulling uh right like this opponent
processing so that
right my level of arousal is constantly
evolving its fittedness to the context
now is it a perfect system no it can go
wrong
but try to make something better than it
it's really really hard so there's a
difference between being a perfect
system and being an optimal system
okay
you face
another problem
what should you pay attention to
that's not what you do
you don't do you're not doing that
at least I hope not
what's actually happening is you've got
a point of processing going on
you've got a default mode Network and a
task Focus Network the task Focus
network is trying to keep you on task
and exclude as much as it can from the
task
push notice what's going on it see it
yeah you see why I want to talk about
this at length
okay pushing away right that's and then
the default mode network is
making you prone
to mind wandering
so if I if I if I was if
suppose this was not a derivately a
riveting interesting talk
I suppose it was really boring I suppose
I was talking about well you know for
quite some time I have been collecting
porcelain cows and the person right and
then what will happen is you will Drift
Away
that's right you will Drift Away
and when you when you're in meditation
you can feel these two all the time and
you're actually playing with them
now if you just drifted away
and be very problematic to you if you
just so why don't I just stay why can't
I just taste task focused the problem
when you stay tax focused is you may not
be noticing what you need to notice
there's not enough variation so the Mind
wandering takes you away it introduces
new things you might think about
and then you kill off most of them
bring them back
and then just keeps doing that that's
how you evolve your attention
there's no boss
that's constantly doing that
you face another problem
there's two sets of problems two kinds
of problems in the world
there are problems that are very
familiar to you very well defined like
24 times three you know what kind of
problem it is it's a multiplication
problem so you know what operations you
can perform you know what the goal state
looks like when you're done doing
multiplication you should have a number
you shouldn't have a picture of a
squirrel
you know and you know what operations
you're allowed to perform you know that
singing is irrelevant
but there are ill-defined problems these
are problems in which your initial State
your goal State and your operations are
unclear to you
I mentioned that in my talk giving a
good talk is a null-defined problem
participating in conversation is a
ill-defined problem
so what should you do
and what you should do is maybe divide
the brain into two systems
one that works to direct attention for
well-defined problems so it
go looks for detail step by step because
if you he and I are both doing a
multiplication problem the one that does
it more step by step with individual
care
is going to do better
so you've got a part of the brain that's
going to be dedicated step-by-step
individual right look for certainty
pursue clarity
that's really good for well-defined
problems we're doing multiplication now
an eagle swoops in towards our head
I don't want to be doing that well is it
an eagle what kind of Eagle is it
so now right when you have you have
problems that require a Gestalt that you
deal with all of the problem sort of all
at once processing everything in
parallel and that part is designed to
deal with ambiguity
and urgency and that's the right
hemisphere
this is Ian the Gilchrist that some of
you know I have a talk with him coming
out soon and what's the relationship
between the left and the right
atmosphere opponent processing through
the corpus callosum to constantly
pulling and pushing on each other
you have another problem
how do I take all of that attention and
and how it comes out in Consciousness
should I should I be doing all of my
processing in consciousness
imagine that imagine that I need to step
I need to get up right consciously
attend to all the muscles in my right
leg consciously contract them you do you
see what I mean
you'll choke
this is the proceduralization the
automatization versus consciousness
and so what what right but you don't
want everything to be unconscious
so what do you have you have opponent
processing between long-term memory
that's largely unconscious
and working memory that's a higher order
relevance field and they're constantly
trading back and forth so your memory
because of that trade-off because of
that opponent processing is not very
accurate
49 of confident eyewitness testimony is
false
that's why we should never convict
people just on eyewitness testimony
there's a woman
watching a TV show
man broke in and assaulted her
she went to the police shortly
thereafter and confidently identified
the man
it was a person she was watching on TV
and it was a live broadcast couldn't
have possibly been him
this was conscious she wasn't aware of
this
and they get fused together most of your
memories like that and yes it's true
your mother didn't really love you
[Laughter]
okay
I can do more and more and more and more
and more about this
artificial intelligence
key breakthrough 1996 Jeff Hinton it's
at the core of all of the Renaissance
that's happening right now
trying to get a neural network to learn
what do you do you get it to compress
the data what's that you try and you try
to get find what's invariant on the same
in all of the data see what my hands are
doing
and then on the basis of that you
internally generate
variations he calls it that he says the
network is fantasizing
and then
that interacts with the world and then
you recompress
and do this again
the variation
compression
Piaget how does a kid learn
kid is constantly trading between two
things assimilation in which it's trying
to make everything fit into its
cognition
an accommodation in which it's
introducing variation in order to fit
that cognition to the world do you see
what's happening here again and again
and again and again machine learning
developmental psychology aspects of your
biology
this is the primary way I'm arguing in
which your cognition
is making the most fundamental sense of
the World by this process you see how it
resonates with everything you're saying
my my big question for you is that one
of the things that I'm suggesting in the
talk and that I'm proposing just in
general in terms of the symbolic
structure is that that that aspect let's
say the right hand and the left hand are
the constant the concentric and
eccentric yes that that is not it
actually exists at all levels of things
that I recognize as having being
my attention but then also if I
participate in anything that is
transpersonal will be true as well that
is that the basketball team has the same
shape
as this attention process that I have
internally okay so let me speak to that
please
so again all right and and
how does evolution biological evolution
work
variation selection variation selection
within a self-organizing cycle it's the
same thing right
and so and that's part of What's called
the Deep continuity hypothesis notice
that by the way that all of Jonathan's
images were embodied left and
right-handedness
have you ever wondered why do you have
we have handedness it's an opponent
processing it's a solution to opponent
processing
other primates don't we do
at least that's one good theory of it
what if this is the Deep grammar
that we keep converging on on how
we make sense of things how we latch on
to the intelligibility of the world
and what if it's a grammar that's
exactly like evolutionary adaptivity
it's about fitting too
conforming to use older language to
the intelligibility of the world
now here's a proposal if that is such a
fundamental grammar and we keep seeing
it in fact remember you had the fractal
fractal levels
all levels and I haven't I can give you
tons more examples and tons more
argument please read some of my
published papers
why is this do we does this keep coming
by the way this is what's being
developed in predictive processing
models too most of
yeah I'm pretty confident to say this
most of the advances that are going on
in AGI right now are just taking this
idea and getting it better implemented
so the point I'm going to make and I'll
be quiet
if this is the fundament of
intellect and I don't mean in our modern
scent of an intellect like the snooty
person who's read too much thought I
mean in the ancient sense that that
ability for us to grok onto patterns in
the world sorry many of you wouldn't
know that reference that's a Robert
Hyland
strangers strange but to to adaptively
fit to the world
and if we reject the Cartesian proposal
that that's imposed on an on on on an
otherwise indeterminate world but
instead adopt a realist position
then you have to conclude that there
must be something fundamentally
corresponding to that grammar in the
grammar of things
there has to be a grammar to grammar
Conformity or else we are actually
severed in terms of the fundamental
grammar of the intelligibility of the
world and our intelligence
and then we are trapped in a kind of
profound skepticism and solipsism so if
you reject skepticism and solipsism then
I think you led to this and that's how I
would say the inner grammar and the
outer grammar
are are deeply deeply interpenetrating
and reflective of each other that's how
I wanted to address your second Point
does that make sense no I mean I of
course I I totally agree that's for sure
it's freaky that it's in those pictures
yeah
I'm happy that
so but so so now if we come down to
it come down to specific things so if
you think of breathing
that seems to be what's going on at
least phenomenologically that I think
that's probably why breathing has always
been such an important aspect of
spiritual practice because it is it is a
it is a um
stabilization and let's say conscious
participation in the Gathering and right
and letting go it's an active symbol
yeah and if you look at for example in
the in the Orthodox tradition we have a
main prayer for mystical practice which
is we call the Jesus prayer and so the
Jesus prayer
Lord Jesus Christ Son of God have mercy
on me a sinner so it's and it's a
usually we say Lord Jesus Christ Son of
God Inspire Inspire breathe in have
mercy on me a sinner
expire and so that structure is there in
the prayer and is there in the breathing
those two things together
and so it becomes this
it becomes like the simplest way you
could say of participating in the this
pattern the basic pattern but then the
that's why like especially the Orthodox
Church you could say something like the
entire liturgy is contained in that
prayer but then it gets expanded
socially and and and say in terms of all
our other gestures into everything else
that we do and all the processions and
all this entering and exiting of the
priests from the holy place and all of
these movements are all these that say
complex
representation or complex participations
in the basic invocation so if you don't
like the fact of the prayer think of the
prayer at least the concept of the
prayer right which is this idea of the
two aspects of of of prayer right this
this call up and and invoking and then
this let's say letting go or realizing
that I'm that I'm not that right it's
like bringing in and letting go it's as
the basic movement of prayer and then
that becomes moves all the way into all
the other aspects of the of the of the
Liturgy and then in the art and all that
so it's like this fractal practice that
is completely coherent together from the
deepest mystical prayer into the final
you know the the highest say the most
complex aspect of a monastic life which
has these daily hourly prayers that are
com that are super complicated but that
they all know that this is just a
an explicitation of this one basic
pattern
so I want to I want to say two two
things to that
first there's something very something
very similar in a projana practice uh so
as I exhale
I let my I I let my attention
move more and more so I'm attending more
and more to attention until I get into
that where I'm as in as I can possibly
be
and then
yeah when I exhale okay okay because the
attention right and then as I in because
you're following you're following the
movement of the stomach okay all right
you see the stomach's coming in when you
exhale so you're following that right
and then when you inhale you go out to
the farthest you could go in a
contemplative practice and then you are
moving between them like this with the
breath you're scaling up and scaling
down of attention and then what happens
is
it goes from being sequential to
stereoscopic and you
and that is supposed to give you a state
of mind prajna in which you see the
whole in each part and the part
right I says it fits into the hole but
you don't see them sequentially like
that it's like what you do in Reading
where you're reading the letters to read
the word and you're reading the word to
read the letters and so you get the
prognac awareness of the world so
there's a similarity there again with
the the movement of attention it's
interesting though because it's the
opposite because you're following the
you're following the course of the
breath and in the projana you're
following the abdomens movement yeah
it's not but but the intent is exactly
the same it's to get the two movements
coordinated until you get a stereoscopic
integration of the two so you you so you
get the you get the fractal emergency
like you see the par all the parts in
the whole the skinci and tuativa the
hole in all the parts the part the and
how each part contains the whole to see
the world in a grain of sand right oh
that's that I mean I think it's it's
definitely similar at least to the way
it's expressed in the filo Kelly or in
the the mystical fathers uh for them it
is it is it's to say it's very personal
too but there is a sense of there is a
sense that this is an existential
practice which is why it's it's framed
as mercy and sinfulness right so so you
you inspire and you bring the spirit in
right now it really is this whole image
of the spirit right you inspire you
bring the spirit in and then you
recognize your
incapacity because obviously you can't
hold your breath forever and then then
in the expiration you realize the the
breaking like how fragmented you are but
then the the the the mystical the in the
Phila career they say that at some point
I mean don't try this at Home Folks but
that at some point the monks will
actually it will be in tune with their
heart
and that the heartbeat will become the
the Rhythm same thing and and so when
you get an extended like deep projects
your breathing can diminish to almost
nothing and you can feel uh heartbeat
and other things like that happening
yeah very much
so the the so the thing the thing that
comes out for me
then is this
idea that's
right of opponent processing which is
the left and the right hand that you
were doing and there's also the up and
the down right
and then I was thinking about again the
whole manner of the conference
because we were trying to opponent
processing sounds sort of nasty but it's
actually like what all these things I've
been describing in your biology
imagine if the parasympathetic and the
sympathetic system was were an
adversarial processing
where the sympathetic system was trying
to destroy defeat and Destroy and
demolish
the parasympathetic system or vice versa
then you're dead
imagine that the default imagine if the
left and right hemisphere although image
said the left hemisphere is now
dominating too much but imagine if it
became pure adversarial processing but
have you ever thought that this that
let's say a lack of understanding of
these very deep truths is what has led
to something like let's say Marxist
dialectic where there is a sense of of
opposition as the basic structure and
and these these are like let's say the
accusations of the that the Christians
had against the mannequins for example
whether or not some people might say
I've said that they're not totally
justified but the idea that that at the
origin is opposition but it's
adversarial see I'm trying to I'm trying
to make a distinction no I'm saying that
that a misunderstanding of what you're
saying yes is seems to be at the root of
this problem that we're seeing even in
terms so one of the things Jordan has
been doing Jordan Peterson has been
suggesting is that in the political
sphere the right and the left work
should work something like that
exactly and I've been making that
argument independently in conversion
which is democracy is the idea of
opponent process right so the left says
when the left isn't insane and I'm also
going to say the same about the right
the left says human beings are subject
to fate I don't mean in a cosmic sense
but they can be overwhelmed by forces
beyond their control and we should
overwhelm by circumstances by the
wandering of these things on the outside
which will intrude on the plan right
right and then the right when it's not
insane says yes but we're not animals we
are called to personal virtue and
responsibility
and then if they're in a point of
processing together we can constantly
evolve our fittedness as a society and
when you look at how democracy was
understood it was supposed to be that
opponent processing the whole checks and
balance system of the United States
depended on a commitment from everybody
to opponent processing that the best way
I can correct myself is through you the
best way you can correct yourself is
through me but if that gets taken over
by the spirit of adversarial processing
it turns into gridlock and this Mutual
self-destructiveness that is now
overtaking democracies in many places of
the world yeah no I I think this is I
think I mean I to me that we get here is
a way to help understand how crucial
the things that we're like how crucial
these questions are that this you know
when you talk about like if I talk about
fractal structures of of relationships
of right and left towards the center I
have my own language John will talk
about opponent processing in in a more
scientific way the consequences of of
the misunderstanding of that of how that
that functions is you could say is that
the root of a lot of the social problems
that we have so you can understand it in
different ways which is that you can
understand a society that is obsessed
with its identity that is that had
become completely obsessed with that
which makes it what it is and wants to
reduce everything to that and wants to
chop off anything that doesn't fit into
that Central identity and that would be
a problem but you can also understand
another image of a society that is
obsessed with idiosyncrasy that is
obsessed with that which is outside that
is obsessed actually obsessed with that
which is strange to its own identity and
hates its own identity
and then you can understand that that
would also be a problem now wouldn't it
and so this the the right possibility of
these two interacting together
of a love let's say an understanding of
the need of identity for anything to
exist you need an identity for anything
to exist but then also to understand
like when I talked about Saint Peter and
Saint Paul for example it's like the
problem of identity is pride right if if
identity holds itself too much like that
then it thinks it's self-sufficient it
closes itself off and it becomes
prideful and that the problem with that
is that then it falls because it because
it it it will shatter like you can't
hold things together like that forever
and the opposite problem or the opposite
of Saint Paul which is the one arguing
for the stranger remember what Saint
Paul is arguing for we don't need
circumcision we don't need all the law
we don't need the law we don't need
circumcision we don't need these things
you know I'm caricaturing a little bit
but I'm trying to show two tendencies in
already the setting up of the church in
the first century but that if we if we
can we can see that these two structures
these two sides these two pillars work
with each other then we can have a we
can I think we can help heal to the
extent that I don't know if it's really
possible but at least create an
alternative
an alternative space to the to the
gridlock what we were facing in the
world right now
sorry for that speech there
it was a good speech
um
so
I guess
um
what so you know deep deep down you can
you can you can I can talk about other
things self-organizing criticality in
the brain I can talk about small world
Network the brain is constantly trying
to trade between being as efficient as
possible and doing all of that and then
being as sort of uh
as evolvable as possible this is also
called the stability plasticity problem
and and you can see the brain and so we
now have this idea emerging of meta
stability that is the two constantly
interweaving and right and again we this
is what I right because I made my career
out of seeing all these convergences and
then getting people to talk to each
other about it that's and and then you
did this and I was like right and
because it's the convergence of like
if I'd gone into these church I would
have went pretty pictures
that's Jesus yeah maybe those right I
went on the cross right yeah now the
thing to me is there's there's two
there's two things there's two things to
be considering here one is
so the idea that most of what most of
our learning is implicit learning most
of our learning is we're picking up on
complex patterns uh without awareness
and that's what the basis of our
intuition and when we like it we call it
intuition and when we don't like it we
call it Prejudice or our bias
um
and so I can see doing this is a way of
constantly surrounding people with this
so the implicit learning is picking up
on all this and they're get people are
getting a deep sort of intuitive sense
of this that seems no but I think it's
more I think it's more than that I think
it's is it that though too no it is
definitely it's definitely that but I
think it is also the
this is people are going to think this
is weird but it is the most natural
space that is it it is the space in
which we are say the church in this
context would be the space in which we
are the most human because it has
condensed this process which we
experience all the time every time we
grab a cup we have this we have these
implicit with these implicit uh
engagement with these processes whether
it's like how our nation functions or
whatever but there's a manner in which
that is religion yeah yeah there's a man
in which that gets smashed I just
grabbed and brought together
and then just like a
can I say this just like a story right
so like a story is a bunch of stuff like
you know you're the story of Your Love
relationship last I don't know 10 years
and there's all these these down times
in them and there's all this like more
stuff or whatever like whatever how long
it's lasted but it's like there's this
down stuff that has nothing to do with
the love relationship that while you're
also going through this love
relationship you're also working and and
then cleaning your room and doing all
this stuff and then what we do is we
take the Salient points we grab them we
put them together we compress them and
then we're like here so it's like right
and all of a sudden I'm in the pattern
that I recognize to be true
and I'm experiencing as the most real
because it compresses the real into a
thing but so that's in terms of story
but now in terms of think about it in
terms of something like
the think about the Christian church as
this
the the what it's representing is this
image of reality it's compressing it
together it's linking it to the
relationship we have with each other and
then it's making us engage in behavior
that is Chris that is bringing all this
together as well so you're standing in
this space you've got this structure
you've got these people that in like in
Dante are manifesting the the goods and
the virtues to you and then you are
standing you're acting together
you're singing you're processing you're
noticing hierarchy you're participating
in hierarchy you're doing all these
things and so it actually ends up being
it ends up being the it becomes like the
the
root
in terms of experience of all those
other subtle less explicit versions of
it so two things to that first I could
say that about pretty much I think that
that's true for all religious rituals
yeah I think I think of course in terms
of of the Christian church I can explain
it to you more clearly because I
understand the symbols right right we'll
we'll come back to the that that point
you just made about ritual
um but I just wanted to draw one
connection to what's happened here
um
because this was also an Ecclesia it was
a kind of gathering and it's a gathering
in good faith and and one of the ways of
understanding Dia logos is to try to
replace
adversarial debate with opponent
processing between people so it doesn't
mean that the the two sides of this
autonomic nervous system don't
homogenize
the differences have to be maintained
but they actually thereby afford each
other the most mutual self-correction
and then together not him not me but
together we're better at getting towards
the truth fitting reality that's deal
logos as opposed to debate
and when it gets into the Flow State and
heats having insights that are priming
my insight that's deal logo so there's
co-emergence
and and the Brilliance of the designers
of this conference is they gave they
gave opportunity to present positions
and then they put them into that kind of
opponent processing and deal logos
that's what was happening here you were
participating in it you were witnessing
it and you also got to participate in it
and this right Jonathan just a few
minutes ago in his speech
you know it was almost apocalyptic we're
on the right we're we're in a very bad
place
and I want you to see that you are
participating in not some Airy fairy
Utopia you're participating in the real
alternative to that that can re-ground
democracy
[Applause]
and it's really cool that it comes with
these beautiful beautiful pictures I
mean so
um
and for those of you who know me beauty
is not a Sentimental thing for me it's a
profoundly platonic thing so so I just
wanted to say that because I thought
that connected what yeah what you and I
are doing to what is happening here so
the only the point that I wanted to make
or to help people maybe see or
understand that
the way that I described it from this
concentration yeah you can you can but I
was going to challenge you on that right
go ahead go ahead go ahead because I get
it but but the point and this is the
this is the relationship with ritual
right right there's something about the
ritual that's unchanging but this the
work that's being done I'm doing a lot
of work now on ritual knowing knowing uh
thinking through ritual is a great
Anthology and how we know through kind
of knowing we do it's not a big surprise
it's non-propositional
um and what it's doing is trying to
constantly if you're trying to do this
compression in the ritual but rituals
evolve they don't even your pictures
evolved yes yes yes yes yes and I'm
thinking of Paul right that you know
trying to evolve between the now and the
always right right
um and so what I wanted to get is yeah
you get the compression but it's also
varying in each person in the church
that is seeing right right the point
that I want to make in terms of
understanding because I'm trying to help
people to understand why this would
exist because it's not just like we're
going there and there's pretty pictures
the the people that you could see how
that experience of coming together and
and having that experience together in
this in a context like that with all of
these elements would be seen as this the
source of my experience
you see what I'm saying it's like it's
the it's the or the culmination
culmination and source of yes and the
anchoring of the more mundane aspects of
my life okay can I give you an analogy
from the platonic tradition I know
you're not hostile to it no not at all
right so and this is from DC Schindler's
book Plato's critique of impure reason
um which is the the so Plato many of you
are familiar with the parable it should
be called a parable not an allegory the
parable of the Cave the people trapped
in the cave and they're only right the
the shadows and The Echoes by the way
why are they less real because they
they're not multi-esspectual they're not
multi-spectual they don't they can't
open up with inexhaustible
intelligibility so the shadows and The
Echoes are less real remember the people
come out of the cave and they see the
sun and the sun's supposed to be the
metaphor for the good but the thing
about the sun is you don't just see it
if you if you're in a Cartesian frame
you think the point is to see the sun
the point is to realize that you are
made by the Sun
that's just what yeah the sun makes
other things visible it's it but not
only make other things visible it's it's
made the energy that is literally
running your body right all of it the
sun is making you and making visible and
so you are not looking at the sun you
are participating in it the very
processes that are organizing your life
are right are participating in that so
that that's exactly the the idea that no
I'm not looking at it I'm because you
often use that word I'm participating in
it it's not only
coming down to me it's also emerging up
through yeah yeah and what's interesting
is that in the right those who know the
traditional literacy whatever in the
Liturgy you see those two movements yeah
happening at the same time and so we
have these moments where we lift up our
hearts right we lift them up into the
Lord this idea that we who represent we
their images like we who represent the
cherubim we're Gathering all these
things into us and rate and moving up or
offering it up and that's why the
priests right
offer up the host these movements that
we do where we offer up and then there's
an influence from above which comes down
upon it so the the staging of that is
there I think to represent those two
together where we come together we offer
up and then
it comes back down on us the two
movements that you talk about right and
and then that goes to that notion of
participation goes to the argument I was
trying to make about our cognition is
not just representing the
intelligibility of the world it's
participating in the same fundamental
principles yeah okay so now if that's
the case I want to make a proposal to
you yeah
which is right and this is sort of
making use of uh Jennings and showbrock
and Boyd and a lot of people writing
about
ritual right now it's a ritual is
actually going through an innocence
one of the arguments that's coming out
is
rituals are and so just give me a moment
because it'll rituals are in a sense
useless Behavior you're not doing
anything right you're not like making a
house you're not transporting groceries
you're not reproducing you're not even
conversing with people to building
social you're just doing this thing
right
um and then and then but in another
sense
that people they're Universal and the
proposal that's coming out of this is
the idea that what I what you're we're
doing in ritual is we are finding
like what you're saying we're finding
these the these condensations of all of
this
that have the greatest capacity to
transfer to as many domains of our life
as possible right right yeah that's I
think that's exactly the right way to
see it okay so I have a metaphor for
that so I'm just going to stand up for a
sec so I'm going to go I'll be off mic
right
well just generally but if you're in a
bar and people are doing this the
gorilla thing you're pretty safe they
don't know what the hell to do for a
fight you're gonna fight John's gonna
fight they go like this
they take the route they're in a lot of
trouble
and and I talk about looting and
meditation
that you don't ever fight with this
it's called your stance and there's
different Arts have different stances
Obi-Wan does a really weird thing okay
to wipe that
you'll see the metaphor in a second that
is a condensation here's a here's here's
a bunch of things there's a bunch of
positions I need to get into
that actually do something they off they
fit me to that or that
what I want is I want to condense them
each one of those is an optimal grip on
that situation that situation that
situation yes what I want to do is
condense them to the perfect Nexus point
that gives me the easiest place from
which I can get to any of the places I
need to get to does that make sense yeah
that's your meta optimal grip
see that yeah
rituals are condensing to give a meta
optimal grip that gives you the greatest
chance of transfer
that's the proposal yeah
no I think I think that that's exactly
the right way to understand it and it's
also
so you can see it how can I say this so
you can see it represented in the way
that people talk about it's a the in the
Christian liturgy they will
it would be something like let's say the
communion meal right it's a it's a
condensation of what it means to eat
together but it's also a sacrifice at
the same time and it's the relate it's
this relationship between Heaven and
Earth and so in the image all the image
of the Eucharist is like a CR insane
condensation exactly like it there's
there's there's the normal aspect of
eating a meal there's the transgressive
aspect of eating flesh and blood there's
a normal aspect of eating bread and wine
there's there's the fact that it's a
table it's a sacrifice it's all these
things and it's like it's just so crazy
that you would condense all these
categories into this space like in the
middle but it's like yeah but that's it
yes right that's the that's the source
of reality like that's how real that's
how you notice the convergent point of
all these things and that is what when
we look at the story of Christ so one of
the things I'm not going to do it here
but one of the things that I've done is
I'm trying to show you how if you
actually look at the story of Jesus it's
it's a crazy it's an insane story and
because even if you know traditional
storytelling it's like Jesus can't you
don't have stories where someone is like
a warrior and a king and a shepherd and
uh and and a worker and uh and a monk
and he's like all these categories
jammed into this one story like this
doesn't make sense this character
doesn't make sense but that's the point
the point is to is to like grab all
these story structures you know all
these sorts of descent and ascent and
all these different these aspects of the
of the Gods it's interesting because
like a lot of the people that have tried
to criticize Christianity will say well
Jesus is just a copy on all these old
gods and it's like yeah I mean all of
them like every single one of them like
he's the he's all these weird like
things that don't that would never for a
pagan be brought together and it's like
well he's Apollo and he's Dionysus at
the same time he's all these things
gathered into the one and so it's like
that's it so it's like you look at the
image of that person on the throne
and it's like it's that right that
condensation right and it's like and
then that person that's a condensation
of all these things he is the source but
he also ends up being the judge
right because
he's the standard by which all the
multiple aspects get
get let's say compared to or the through
line the through line there you go
through line is found in the multi
aspectual yeah and notice so Freud noted
that a long time ago that
religious symbols and dream symbols have
a tremendous amount of condensation but
he saw it as an Evidence of PR of a
primitive form of thought
but if you pay attention to what a
massive powerful neural network is doing
in deep learning it's doing tremendous
compression
from which it can then create new
variation
that then gets recompressed it's doing
it so many people are now saying no no
maybe the compression or the
condensation is actually especially in
ritual studies is people are taking a
lot of they're using propositions and
pictures I'm not denying that but but
people in rituals are taking a lot of
non-pr propositional complex patterns
and then doing this compression to meta
optimal grip so that that can then vary
out back into their lives in ways that
it is helpful and insightful does that
land for you no that lands that that
lens I think that's exactly what it is
and I think that at least for
I think that at least for a secular
world and a secular audience I think
it's a way for people to to at least
re-understand why these things are exist
okay good good good good okay okay so
here's so you know and we're introducing
ritual and I consider Tai chichwana
ritual in this deep sense and of course
there's there's also I was static there
but and you're also moving you're also
you're evolving one one I'm trying to do
tai chi while I'm sitting in a chair
right and you evolved but there's also
the evolving that I'm talking about and
it gets you to so you're trying to find
the through line so you have all these
different
moves you might do but like but what's
the through line between them right and
that's what the form is there's all
these aspects of fighting but I'm
finding the through line through all of
them right and all of that's going on so
the meta optimal grip but it's a flowing
meta optimal grip
what's the difference
between that
in our everyday lives and the sacred
do you see do you see that because we're
saying this is at the this is how I walk
around the room
but it's also in the ritual
I I I I could in a very realistic sense
I could be using everything we're
talking about to fight you yeah like
martial arts yeah I don't want to I love
you right right but right I'm sure you
could take me John
but what's the difference right do you
see what I'm trying to do no idea what
you're trying to get and so I would see
it as so I would see it as a hierarchy
like a fractal hierarchy that's the way
that I see it yeah so let's think of uh
let's take another ritual which is
closer but Jonathan I've heard you say
the sacred reaches from the very top to
the very that's right so you can't
locate the sacred just at the top no no
definitely not okay what I mean so let's
let's take an example because I talked
about the Eucharist before
so think about a family meal right so a
family meal is ritualized and it does
exactly what you're saying right because
what it does is it is it creates a
common space and a compressed moment in
which you are compressing the
relationships that exist more in flux
and subtle of a family into a ritualized
moment and so we're sitting around the
table you know we set the table we we
learn how to talk to each other we don't
want one person to talk too much you
don't want one person to take too much
food you want to share you want to to to
attend to what the others is doing and
so you're actually ritualizing the the
behavior of your entire family into one
moment like one one one activity okay so
there could be other versions of that
but that's definitely one version Oh
that's a great that's a great and so
what you would let's say
that meal will also have a higher
version of it which will be something
like a wedding Feast let's say yes so
now you have a wedding feast in which we
all come together to eat a meal together
in the celebration of an important event
in our high larger group so there will
be all these rules and rituals about how
to function in that and to properly
function and to not take up too much
attention to focus your intention on the
riding room blah blah blah et cetera Etc
excellent so then you keep going but
then if you raise that up to the last
highest rung you will come to the altar
table
and then the altar table will become the
meal of meals it will become the meal of
the entire Cosmos in the imagery the
cosmic Meal which brings all these
different like rituals together anchors
them but then contains them all together
so to me there's like a there's a
scaling question and so I don't know if
Tai Chi can do that but what I mean is
that so you can understand that there
the sacred exists at the in the family
in the and will pray obviously you'll
pray before the meal you do all these
things so it exists at the level of the
family and then it scales up at
different levels and then there's a
there's in church especially in the
traditional Church we're saying like
this is the equipment like the church is
the kingdom it's the whole thing it's
the final moment it's the eschaton we're
at the end of times all of this is a
gathering in into the final moment of
everything that's what it's represent
that's what if you don't believe that
it's actually happening it's at least
presented that way okay and so it
becomes the anchor for all these other
things and so I'm sure there are
versions of that like let's say
in other yeah there are yeah
but we can we don't even maybe we'll
tackle the pluralism I'm not I wasn't
bringing that up for that no I'm trying
to see I'm trying to get to the scaling
part of the Sacred like how it but but
so but you brought in something really
really interesting let me see if I'm
getting it right so we've been doing a
lot of horizontal condensation and
opening right transfer appropriate
processing is right uh the the the Cog
PSI term right and and that but you now
just said you know but there's also
transfer appropriate up and down yeah is
that is that oh yeah and so is the
tutoring oh sorry that's the wrong word
is the education in the sense of educing
going also up and down namely does what
happens in the family meal
it goes from bottom up too if you have
yeah yeah you won't if you have improper
family is any proper family meals then
that wedding will go back but it will go
bad and then people will hate each other
in church like it's gonna build it's
gonna go up it's gonna go up that way
too
that's 100 sure yeah so so so now we're
trying to find so a really
powerful I don't that's not quite the
right adjective but I'll use it as a
placeholder a really good powerful
ritual is one that would be the Nexus
both of horizontal transfer and vertical
transfer is that is that right
so would part of what it is to be a wise
person is to be able to
either find create or participate in
that kind of Nexus ritual
because if this is the Machinery of
intelligence and the Machinery of
intelligibility and we need it to do
optimal this way and this way a wise one
way to distinguish a wise person from a
less wise person is that they could find
the Nexus point and share it with others
is that is that a reasonable proposal I
think so I don't know
I'm not saying that's the only
characteristics no no no no I would say
that in terms of wisdom which is a which
is a let's say I don't know a moral
virtue or it would I don't I don't
regard wisdom on some moral virtue okay
so we might be using the term slightly
differently go ahead so I would say I
would tend to see what you're saying in
terms of of of the goods in terms of
human interaction that's the way that I
would see it mostly it's like a person
will become a Nexus for a virtue and
then we'll we'll become like a Rippling
Pond for the world like an anchor and
will Ripple but I'm not sure like you
have to find yourself to that point like
you have to find your way to that right
uh I mean you if you'll allow me to
complementally to you you're displaying
a kind of wisdom in pointing this out
you can find your way through a lot of
this yeah you don't just know it you
grasp the significance of it and you
have insight into it so you can right
yeah the reason why I'm hesitating is
that
my experience is that most people who
make up rituals they don't succeed like
the rituals have to be anchored somehow
in something which is given no no no no
no no that's my but I think I think
you're agreeing with me but okay if
you're not let me let me know but this
is how I think you're agreeing with me
most attempts at ritual fail yes yeah
yes yes
which means there's a normativity in
them yes and I'm proposing that the
normativity is this sort of meta optimal
grip on these two Dimensions that
enhances transfer is that is that okay
yeah yeah and I agree I agree right and
so an individual who was better at
getting the meta optimal grip
horizontally and vertically and
coordinating them together would be
somebody that presumably can help other
people get to the place that sort of
optimizes what we've everything we've
been talking about is is that okay yeah
yeah that's fine okay so you are still
agreeing with her okay okay and so what
I'm then saying is
the why wisdom to see to have insight to
to zero in on what's most relevant to to
find a meta optimal grip these are I
think these are all consonant with each
other I'm saying the wise person
succeeds precisely because they are
Guided by the normativity that
distinguishes a good Ritual from a bad
ritual and they have learned to track it
well that's what I'm proposing okay yeah
I mean maybe I'm not sure what the
corollaries of that are like I I'm like
I don't know what that means what would
it look like let's say what would it
look like it would look like the person
who could move between
who could do this at the family dinner
help coordinate the condensation and
then how it also re-particularizes so
the family flows well and then and then
when the kid gets married knows how to
right educate his kids so that they go
into the ceremony the wedding ceremony
right and then also can participate
perhaps at your altar table in a way
that other people find wow that was and
they can move between them and and you
get and and they are conducive to other
people being able to participate in
depth that's what I'm proposing to you
no I agree I think that would definitely
be that would be an aspect let's say of
a wise person yeah I'm not claiming
that's the essence of wisdom that I I
said that before I think there's a lot
more to wisdom but I'm what I'm what I'm
I'm having a realization about a
dimension let me call it a ritualistic
in the good sense of the word Dimension
to wisdom that I hadn't thought of
before
yeah yeah no I think that's a good it's
a good it might actually be a good place
to to stop as well because I'm looking
at the time
everybody's just quiet
as if
as if this discussion is over it's not
or this discussion is never over we can
we have to stop the discussion but
there's no way this discussion is over
the only good thing that start ever said
was you never complete anything good you
abandon it
foreign
thanks everybody thank you so very much
thank you everyone for coming if you
could give our speakers another round of
applause